Christopher asks what are your thoughts
on employing friends Christopher this is
a great question for a lot of people who
watch my stuff they they make that
connection on the family business thing
I get enormous amounts of excuse me
email from people that are the sons and
daughters of business owners because
they knew my narrative now that I'm
running Vayner with AJ I'm getting some
more brother and sister stuff and I'm
getting a little older and I'm even
getting some of the perspective from the
dads and the moms I have employed
friends at both Wine Library and
vaynermedia vaynermedia was started with
five of AJ's dear friends and I think
the the number one advice I'd say is you
should absolutely
I'm emphatic about this and and you as
you guys know I'm big on you know do
what works for you but I'm a huge fan of
hiring friends especially early on to
establish culture to have those
teammates in the trenches especially if
you're willing to practice meritocracy
right so the key to friends is that here
we are five years later and AJ's five to
six high school and college friends that
started the company with us are in
different places within the organization
and not really treated any differently
at the highest levels than anybody else
and and and very honestly I hope they're
not listening or watching the show they
may even be treated slightly harder and
worse than everybody else because I'm so
sensitive to it in the other direction
I expect the six of you not to hit me up
for a race and so I think that I'm a big
fan of it I recommend it it is risky you
I have fired my friends in the past
Brandon was my best friend growing up he
runs Wine Library risky it you know it
really comes down to here's my belief my
belief is very simple if you lose a
friendship from somebody working for you
and not working out and you having to
fire them or them leaving then your
friendship wasn't as strong as you
thought and that is the bottom line
I didn't do it I didn't do it oh crap
wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe